la crainte d'une catastrophe écologique
d'envergure ne cesse d'augmenter à l'île
maurice depuis plus de deux semaines le
wac à chiots et échoué sur la côte
sud-est de cette terre située dans
l'océan indien
le vraquier qui appartient à un armateur
japonais mais battant pavillon panaméen
voyager à vie tout en transportant 200
tonnes de diesel et 3800 tonnes d'huile
lourde des hydrocarbures très polluants
qui ont déjà commencé à s'échapper du
navire face à la menace d'une marée
noire les autorités mauriciennes ont
demandé jeudi le soutien de la france
un appel à l'aide entendu par paris
lorsque la biodiversité est en péril il
y a urgence d'agir
la france est là aux côtés du peuple
mauricien vous pouvez compter sur notre
soutien cher praveen drogue note
nous déployons dès à présent des équipes
et du matériel depuis la réunion ce
samedi la france a donc commencé à
livrer son aide en équipements et en
personnel depuis l'île voisine de la
réunion un avion tactique de transport
militaire ainsi qu'un navire de la
marine nationale achemine une dizaine
d'experts et plus de 6 tonnes de
matériel dont des barrages côtiers et du
matériel de pompage
c'est la première fois que nous sommes
confrontés à une catastrophe pareille et
nous ne sommes pas suffisamment équipé
pour traiter ce problème
inquiète d'une aggravation de la
situation les autorités mauriciennes ont
aussi demandé le soutien de l'afrique du
sud